lips mamadou bah merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le
traitement par chloroquine se poursuit
au sénégal après visiblement des
résultats encourageants en france aussi
c'est un sujet toujours controversé
un haut responsable de la lutte contre
la maladie indique que les malades
guérissent plus vite c'est un avis
partagé au sénégal il ya des études
c'est un vrai espoir quand cela se passe
effectivement c'est un avis très partagé
par la population
ce que depuis le commencement de la fin
génie
le professeur moussa ces geeks et de
chef du département d'infectiologie de
l'hôpital fann a suivi le travail du
professeur de marseille c'est qu'il ya
eu un impact vraiment significatif sur
le traitement de cette maladie
aujourd'hui nous arrivons à guérir avec
eux cette c'est mieux puis le 194 malade
est aujourd'hui 135 qui sont sous
traitement et la maladie est en cours au
je peux dire le trouver une solution
médicale au niveau de l'hôpital de
femmes alors le président macky sall ne
sera plus tenu de passer par l'assemblée
nationale pour légiférer sur des
questions d'ordre économique budgétaire
financière juridique sanitaire
sécuritaire pendant trois mois une
décision pour éviter de réunir à
l'assemblée nationale et protéger ses
membres
est ce que cela traduit une vraie prise
de conscience de la situation
effectivement c'est une vraie prise de
conscience de l'homme de la situation
parce que le 24 mars le président de la
république que ap une décision majeure
de détendre les mesures prises amélie b
le contrôle avec le couvre-feu est
intégrée par les grades des chances et
sur ce il a saisi l'assemblée nationale
directement pour voter une loi de
réhabilitation et ses lois propose au
président de la république de pouvoir
gouverner par ordonnances pendant trois
mois ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
pouvons passer sur des décisions qu'ils
vont vraiment
à l'encontre de la population mais pour
les protéger on peut passer à ces
mesures d'urgence jusqu'à tant de
décisions de moi je comment la création
d'un fonds d'urgence de 1000 milliards
de francs cfa environ ce qu'on peut dire
un euro contre 1 2 milliard de nous et
les non seulement le personnel médical à
lutter contre ce fléau comme ce bus de
les aider sur le plan du matériel et qui
matériaux en plus de ça des médicaments
et ce plan aussi aider aussi à une bonne
partie pour aider les entreprises qui
sont impactés par cette situation on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
beaucoup de secteurs de l'économie
sénégalaise est paralysée par ses passes
cette pandémie
on ne peut pas y aller ni en tout cas
ils sont choqués c'est d'être là jouent
yens au moins l'opposition qui craint au
contraire de donner une trop grande
liberté d'action au président le texte
pourrait justifier des législations qui
n'aurait rien à voir avec l'épidémie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
l'opposition sénégalaise est dans son
rôle on ne peut pas l'empêcher de donner
son avis et de dire aussi ici deux sont
d'accord ou pas parce que le rôle de
l'opposition
c'est le contrôle et le pouvoir exécutif
outre je pense qu'on doit les écouter et
prendre conscience qu'ils sont en train
de berck
mais à cette heure où la situation est
grave et très grave il faut des mesures
que d'autres nous devons être dans
l'union et ses lions que fait la force
nous devons tous être ensemble derrière
le président de la république vous
trouver les solutions
vous trouvez des moins bons en ligue et
se glisse et gagner cette guerre
sanitaire qu'on a entrepris avec tous
les toutes les organisations de la
société civile des chefs religieux des
acteurs de développement
tout ce qui sort de venir ensemble
d'élire le président de l'apli pour
trouver une solution rapide adéquat pour
barrer cette soluce au niveau des pays
alors on voit ces images de désinfection
des rues de dakar est-ce que c'est
efficace en tout cas ça n'a pas été
encore prouvé me semble-t-il où c'est de
la communication
je ne sais pas si c'est efficace ou non
mais nous l'avons eu
mais nous avons vu que ça a été braqué à
wayne dans la ville où l'épicentre
une valise a été au niveau de lâcher ça
a été pratiqué aussi en corée du sud
pourquoi pas le sénégal ne doit pas
l'adopter pour trouver des solutions et
des essais les désinfecter tous ces
luttes lui ces places publiques ont fait
deux tués les us
quel est l'état de la population quel
est l'état d'esprit de la population
sénégalaise on a vu un le décès de pape
diouf tic qui a marqué beaucoup de monde
également en français ce qui la
constitue un vrai choc n'était pas
n'importe qui c'était une très grande
personnalité du pays c'était un monument
un immense cinéma personnalités du monde
du foot de la culture et d'art
aujourd'hui avec son décès à cause de ce
virus qui l'a emporté on peut dire que
ça y est on n'aime pas vraiment
important sur la population sénégalaise
qui dès maintenant a pris conscience de
l'urgence de respecter les consignes
décrété par le gouvernement de rester
dans les maisons et de suivre tout ce
que le président indécis contenir se
faisait par exemple
par exemple le couvre feu mis en place
par le gouvernement il est bien
respectée aujourd'hui ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous tandis que le coffret est respectée
même s'il ya des queues de castor
on peut dire que ça a été respectée par
une bonne partie de détendu qui
découvrira que ça soit à dakar que ça
soit un pouvoir qui est le deuxième
ville la plus touchée pas ses juristes
on peut dire que au niveau de toutes les
régions du sénégal
ça a été respectée merci beaucoup amadou
bâ d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
au groupe afrique de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe